dramatic moment Hunter's lawyer told
prosecutors sweetheart deal was off
after judge eviscerated agreement
Apparently one of the guys yelled out I
think this was um Biden lawyer Chris
Clark said I don't know what you're
trying to accomplish then we'll rip it
up he says you can't get around that so
basically what happens is they go in
Hunter Biden's gonna supposed to plead
guilty to this sweetheart deal where
it's a slap on the rest of no jail time
the judge then says well hold on there a
minute
this doesn't include any Farah
violations any potential fire of this
plea agreement just tax evasion right so
are you going to charge him later on the
prosecution says we could Biden's
lawyers are like hey no way no way
the judge then's like what's going on
looks at the deals off they have to go
uh there's a recess they negotiate it
looks like the deal might be back on now
the deal's on hold here's what people
are speculating it seems that Hunter
Biden's lawyers went to these these
prosecutors
and the deal was they will not prosecute
Hunter on anything if he just accepts
these little charges and a slap on the
wrist
it only says on paper these charges but
trust us we're not going to come after
you for anything else but the judge
asked the question if the judge just
rubber stamped it it'd be done and their
back room deal is done but the judge was
like what about pharah well the
prosecution can't lie it's a question
effect can you charge him well we can
they get mad saying you're you're double
crossing us that's what it seems like it
seems like some shady back room dealing
to throw some red meat at the press and
create a scenario where the media will
say hunter Biden pleads guilty look the
doj is not biased they went for the
president's own son what do you mean
they're going after Trump for political
reasons they went after the president's
son it's totally non-biased but that
back room deal was no good when the
judge spotted it what are the pharah
what's pharah uh the four was it foreign
agent registration excellent like that
that if you're uh acting on behalf of a
foreign government you have to register
and Hunter Biden was with barisma and
probably a bunch of other countries and
he did not well that's that's odd do you
think you I mean personally if the judge
didn't know this
and the ju if they got any other judge
and that judge is like looks in order to
me I guess bang done wasn't Hunter
Biden's computer full of pornography
well yeah yeah so it's just the whole
thing is is obviously very very sad but
it also just shows the state of the
culture right that you know the
president even the first family right
the son is involved in all these things
and I think it's one thing to talk about
tax evasion it sounds like it happened
and he's pleading guilty but all of
these other things you know think about
it we don't I think as a society we're
not hard on porn we think porn's fine
everyone we say everyone most people use
it it's not a big deal it's legal and so
you know Hunter Biden can do all this
stuff and it's crazy and then oh but he
did tax evasion so that's the bad thing
that he did
this is crazy let me read this
and all the stuff about prostitutes and
strippers and it's just it's all all
dark stuff norika warned lawyers the
deal was unprecedented and possibly
unconstitutional and could prevent
prosecutors from going after Biden for
other crimes in the future she insisted
she was acting in Hunter's interest by
making sure he knew exactly how much
protection he would or would not get
under the deal but she also unloaded on
it sometimes in personal terms about the
position it put her in as an Arbiter you
keep telling me that I have no role I
shouldn't even be reading this thing she
vented her admonitions force a tense
negotiation if the judge left her
courtroom teams of lawyers faced off and
talks for an hour to the hearing they
had to hash out among themselves what
exactly they had agreed to then sell it
to a judge who was increasingly
skeptical
the end result ended in a politically
perilous day delay for Biden's campaign
set to be helmed from Wilmington in a
state blah blah blah blah blah we get it
this is crazy
that the judge was it was so shocked the
judge said the unprecedented nature of
the agreement forced her to step in but
bizarrely she also said she sympathized
with Hunter Mr Biden I know you want to
get this over with she told him at the
end of the three-hour slugfest which had
the effect of pushing off Hunter's plea
and extending his legal woes into late
Summer and the fall as his father gears
up his presidential re-election campaign
so maybe Roseanne was right about those
military tribunals right interesting
I I mean I I it still blows my mind that
he's got he's gotten away with as much
as he's gotten away with that that this
is the that he might be able to
still might be able to walk away from
this with it with a plea deal it's it's
I don't have a whole lot more to add
other than it's just really a a black
pill it's my opinion yeah it's the most
uh Emperor has no clothes thing and that
what that metaphor is is like everyone
can see that the emperor's not wearing
anything but ever but the emperor is
telling people oh I'm wearing a robe so
everyone's like yeah he's wearing a robe
but they all know he's not and then it's
a little kid that's like he's not
wearing any clothes so like we all know
Hunter Biden did this stuff the evidence
is there I mean I I maybe we should say
I don't know but it is very apparent
there's a lot of evidence and uh for Joe
Biden just to be pretending that it's
that it's like not a big deal it's the
most insane abuse of power legal
Authority an executive Authority in this
country I've ever seen in my lifetime
I mean I saw George Bush take the world
to war because of weapons of mass
destruction that didn't exist this is
the most disgusting thing I've ever seen
a president do this is robbing our
culture of the truth
it's it is not healthy we need to change
this war is pretty bad um yeah yeah but
it's been happening my whole life this
is like
brainwashing people to be evil that
doesn't make war less bad but I get what
you're saying but this is like it's like
so in plain sight which makes it in my
opinion more disgusting it's like little
kids are like it's okay to lie well it's
interesting because I think you know the
president is such I the liar word is a
good one for him because he professes
this Faith so you know I'm Catholic as
many people know you know I became
Catholic in college and Joe Biden says
like it's Catholic like he ran kind of
on the Catholic Grandpa and this good
man and the uniter I'm this you know man
of integrity and you know separate from
this whole Scandal right he is the most
pro-abortion president the most
pro-sexual deviancy president in
probably our history Maybe Obama was up
there on abortion but he is he's been
more pro-abortion than even Obama so the
White House is a discrete
and you saw like the topless
um you know uh you know woman or man who
was dressing as a woman and had you know
fake breasts topless there were three
that were topless I mean what a shame
that this let's become our white house
and our leadership pro-abortion
pro-sexual deviancy Pro chaos and
unreality you know a man is a woman
woman is a man
it's like the worst thing he's done but
he also sniffs kids and like the
inappropriately touches them and things
like that that is very weird too it
might be the time it's odd the time and
the place because we need I feel like
the Earth is in the most desperate
situation it's ever been in my lifetime
right now and we need real like
straightforward leadership so it's like
coupled with that it's from like what he
did yeah it's guys it's not that bad he
just lied about his son being an abusive
pornography guy or whatever but like or
or a lot he had his son do Billion
Dollar Deals it's like okay it's not as
bad as murdering a hundred thousand
people or murdering a million babies
allowing million babies a year to be
murdered but we need like George Bush
had the leeway to take us to war in
2003. we don't have the leeway to mess
around right now this is like get your
together or we're done I think he
just needs to be voted out ASAP I mean
there's no there's no I pray for the
president actually I pray for I believe
conversions are possible but it is it is
we are in a severe crisis because of
this not just because of this white
house obviously it's lending to the
problem there's just systemic rot right
now across the country I don't know if
you were going to ask this Phil but what
will happen is if we don't seize moral
Authority on Earth it'll become the
economic forum and the Chinese Communist
party will seize where do we ground our
moral Authority right and that goes back
to the stuff that you know we were
talking about earlier but if we don't
get first things right first human
rights are protected for the most
vulnerable members of a society if we
can't treat the most vulnerable
correctly and if we can't shape you know
men are off with hookers and pornography
and women are on only fans I mean all of
this cultural chaos that were enveloped
in where are we going to have the moral
authority to go say we're better than
China we're going to go to war with
China we need to fix the rot in our
country and in our culture I feel like
if Ian was dictator of the earth it
would be the most rural totalitarian
regime ever experienced it would be it
would be one hell of a ride man forced
DMT there's no way oh okay yeah
I don't think there's any way to dictate
Earth that's the most insane thing not I
mean has a lot of good intentions it's
just we've got it we gotta form the
conscience form our morality I don't
think porn well first I think porn means
a lot of things there's really horrible
sex going on on the internet on YouPorn
and things but then there's also really
loving sex happening on YouPorn like you
see the occasional video two people that
really like each other and like is that
that Thing You Porn yeah it's
youporn.com you know it's a it's just
porn site yeah but if it's if it's
Beauty if it's beautiful loving sex
between two people and it's truly loving
then it should be for just them in the
context of marriage and it's gonna
potentially bring life into the world
because sex is designed to do that and
so they need to be prepared to raise
those children and they shouldn't be
selling it for people to watch on the
internet well it's literally loving sex
I've learned how to have sex from
certain videos
like different positions different
different
um rhythms like and and that's like was
help helpful for me in the long run so
if so I don't think it's all evil and
like we should just never watch Ever sex
I personally well I think it that's an
interesting question because I think if
for example I think if you're in a a
marriage and you are wanting to love
your spouse better I think it's
absolutely appropriate to learn more
about sex so that you can learn how to
have the best sex with your spouse and
the best way to do that is with your
spouse right that's what I think
um not by watching other people have sex
well that I mean if you sometimes if
people are in an insulated environment
they just repeat the same thing over and
over and over again that's all they know
because they don't know there's other
methodologies the problem with watching
people have sex is typically people do
that so that they can have sexual
gratification from that yeah it's not
it's not like a class I agree with that
because for orgasm it's pornography for
orgasm typically if you let your mind
think of the person on the video that's
like demoralizing but if you watch the
porn and then think about your
girlfriend
that's like a healthy I found it feels a
lot healthier and I use the technique on
the girlfriend
well I would say that sex is for two
people who have committed each other to
each other for life and that they're in
that commitment they're willing to bring
children into the world because sex
brings life even when you use
contraception it fails 50 of the people
who have abortions were using
contraception so contraception is not
some fail safe it fails you know it
doesn't always work and so marriage is
the beautiful solution to all of this
and in a marriage I think you can
definitely you know maybe uh study about
how do we have sex with each other
better but I don't think pornography is
any role in that I've heard people say
well we watch porn as a couple in order
to have a stronger more loving
relationship and I don't think that
really works in the real world one of
the top reasons for divorce is
pornography I wonder if the end result
second top reason listed for why people
divorce is pornography at the end of the
day your sexually visualizing someone
who's not your spouse I wonder you
should Reserve that for just results
because that's your one flesh you've
committed to just like the left upload
their brains to computers and then
humans
the conservative humans just stay and
have families and live normal
traditional human lives do you think oh
what do you say though well I mean to
Tim's Point I've I've mentioned before I
think at some point there's going to be
like actual protection for people that
are not augmented like the way that we
have carved out space for the Amish in
in the United States how they don't have
to follow the same laws that everyone
else says there will be people that are
going to say I'm not going to get any
kind of augmentation or whatever and
there's going to be people that are
going to be augmented that are going to
have to protect them from other people
that are augmented like real sci-fi kind
of and they're like but here's the
thing I mean the whole thing about well
the traditional people will go to the
traditional things and then everyone
else will go crazy I think all people we
have the same human nature and so we
have a lot of shared struggles right and
then bad ideology can make us do bad
behaviors that ultimately can warp our
Natures but I think all people are
called to the same goodness and so I
would say liberal on the left should get
married too they should have children
too they should be faithful too they
should be against pornography and
abortion and all these things too and I
think some are I mean I know for example
I know some more progressives entering
the pro-life movement and a lot of them
doing amazing work in the public
movement and many of them are as they're
learning about sex and life and
bioethics many of them are becoming not
just pro-life but they're becoming okay
I'm pro-marriage I'm Pro these more
Traditional Values but I can still maybe
have more left-leaning beliefs on maybe
immigration or these other topics but
they're very passionate about marriage
now as well as life and as you know what
are seen as the more traditional value
so I think their Traditional Values are
not just for conservatives if they're if
it's true if it's morality it should be
for everybody like I do think men and
women are are different testosterone I
just started working out like a week two
weeks ago and my testosterone's been out
of control like my sex drive has been
like a rocket and I important
information yeah I thank you Tim and uh
I think if there's like absolute
conversation tonight especially
considering
I know I know but Ian talking about
fairly intimate details about his to the
top history oh continues but it feels
like absence I'm loving it thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time